special when you talk about a
the story about the dog with the uh the
girl with Down Syndrome
it's so I don't I don't want to give it
away oh yeah I don't want to give it
away because it's uh it's it's so funny
and so really so true it's so so true
but it's also really true happened in
real life and it was a wild moment in my
life where when it happened I thought
yeah uh I was so embarrassed so
embarrassed I was so embarrassed but it
was but that yeah led to kind of
the uh
great Arc of the special because I I you
know people ask why it's called
cheeseburger and then it's explained in
it why I I call it that yeah it's
because of an emotional moment I had and
it is it ties to a lot of my feelings
about culture and comedy and
and the way we perceive stuff and that
story is part of it yeah like enjoy the
cheeseburger enjoy that cheeseburger
baby